saunas are very good
justin bieber is redefining what it
means to pimp my ride
showing off his luxurious tour bus i'm
having a good time
in honor of covering the may issue of gq
the singer invited the mag on his lavish
bus for a look around and
it does not disappoint here's where i
watch
the toronto maple leafs absolutely
demolish the ottawa senators
it's not real but there is a fireplace
here which is kind of cool
aesthetic and naturally what's a tour
bus without art we got
some art here by my friend joe termini
and it's uh some of my favorite art
it's called cash only you can check it
out here and don't even get us started
on the bedroom or should i say
master bedroom suite so um on the road
uh this is where i where i sleep so i
spend most of my time
back here laying down watching movies
getting rest but the most amazing
feature the bathroom which justin
casually reveals includes a steam shower
and an infrared sauna what's so cool
about this is when i'm on tour
i gotta make sure that i keep my body on
optimal
level because there's so much uh that
goes into
touring and it's really hard on your
body you're doing like an
hour and an hour and a half show a night
which is similar to a professional
athlete
in the video justin reveals he purchased
the tour bus last year and one of his
first adventures was taking it on a road
trip from his hometown in canada
all the way to los angeles with his wife
haley bieber i just think there's
there's something about
being in your own safe comfortable
environment that you just feel
comfortable and safe and protected i
don't know and this is the biebers we're
talking about here
so you know even when they're on the
road they keep their fashion game
on point there's a compartment
downstairs
down below to keep my clothes but then
there's some of this stuff too
which is some of this is hayley's and
some of it's mine which are all these
little tucked away
spots
you know speaking of haley justin also
dishes to gq
about his marriage revealing in the mag
that their first year together was
actually really tough adding that there
was still trauma he was dealing with
alluding to his highly publicized
troubles as a child star
he explains quote there was just a lack
of trust there was all these things that
you don't want to admit to the person
that you're with because it's scary you
don't want to scare them off by saying
i'm scared i've gotten to a place where
i have like a
core group and people who are really
supporting me and encouraging me and
i never had that before however justin
says he and haley have overcome those
hurdles and are now
creating moments together as a couple
before i didn't have that to look
forward to in my life
my home life was unstable like my home
life was not existing i didn't have a
significant other
i didn't have someone to love i didn't
have someone to pour into
but now i have that having that
stability and feeling grounded is a
sentiment the singer previously shared
with et
in 2015. i never created those type of
relationships so
now it feels like i can step into more
uncomfortable environments and then step
back into like my circle